we fought a lot when we made the first
record it took about I mean it was
mostly about it we were passionate about
it we really wanted the same things we
wanted to get out there like great music
and be able to stand by fast forward and
simple plan have at least five hit
records sold over seven million albums
worldwide and released nineteen epic
music videos addicted that was a really
fun video when you stole you almost
didn't make that video we're like nine
hours late we had to like film until
like 7:00 in the morning to finish it
summer paradise it was awesome I don't
remember most of it
[Music]
the last scene of the video if you
notice that David is not there because
he actually literally passed out from
hanging out with Sean Paul we couldn't
wake him up
it is lifelike now for you guys that
some of you are dads and you're
traveling you know I'm just I'm saying
it's it's a different life it's fun it's
really it's I think for us we had to
it's 15 years now from the first record
so we've partied a lot we've traveled a
lot we see in the world had so many fun
experiences that being home now is kind
of like it's exciting
but the guys are putting their home
lives on hold for the majority of the
year touring the world and celebration
of their 15th anniversary and attached
to wanted to see that there was room for
her as the band's new drummer I just
like the fact that your arms are around
me I'm lying a lie it's not unpleasant
ok friends we are friends after a little
practice it's looking like the Tash you
may have a new gig on her hands I'm like
completely useless like Anne Hathaway